by the way I want to say that Mandy
Patinkin has joined the cast of our show
really yeah yeah he's now a full member
and he's reporting on the wack pack hi
Mandy hey Howard has a dog oh wait a
second that's Shirley with a big beard I
thought it was a pirate is that Johnny
Depp hi Shirley
let's go to sea and get our fortune it's
a pretty awesome beard look at that
[ __ ] thing it's the only spot where
hair grows these days so you guys know
Mandy went Hank in on homeland with
Claire Danes
very intense beard it's very beautiful I
mean it's that contagious
thank you a lot to think it's like an
it's got its dark in the front and gray
on the side rabbi would you get up close
Hell's Angel looks like right hem have a
motorcycle with that Shirley what I said
can I tell you something seriously yeah
I don't know where you're gonna be in
the future but be careful around mel
gibson he looks like a jewish by car
you'd be like the juice of anarchy
Shirley's like gone full tabia from
fiddler
what is he you know I think he took up
religion during the pandemic all day
long I bitty bitty bum if I was a
loyalty man you should come out like
Tevye with you do it your ass yeah
that's liked have you we'd make a play
Shirley on the roof
you